benvenuti nell ultima puntata della
stagione del leccio con karim usa siamo
bravi siamo pronti
[Musica]
no
che tra l'altro per me un teatro voto è
la perfetta rappresentazione di youtube
i pinguini tattici nucleare
[Musica]
st
benvenuti 18 dicembre sono stato
all'anteprima di amici come prima
non è un caso ho espressamente chiesto
di farmi andare gratis non sono
responsabile del loro ritorno al cinema
ma mi piace pensarlo tra l'altro loro
dicono di non aver mai litigato e che
tutto era un grande scherzo una burla un
gioco di ponte certo e lino banfi e il
nostro rappresentante italiano
all'unesco scherzo o meno ho voluto
esserci a tutti i costi ed essendo la
mia primissima anteprima cinematografica
voglio raccontarvi tutto
questa è stata l'anteprima di amici come
prima
[Musica]
quel martedì prendo al volo il primo
treno per milano
e siccome sono un influencer content
cliente youtuber via in pizza con oltre
un milione di iscritti
mi siedono i posti prioritari e mentre
osservo il nulla dal finestrino
penso a quello che potrebbe accadere
nella sala non so solo molto ingenuo ma
è stata la mia prima anteprima
non sapevo cosa aspettarmi
non ero neanche sicuro che ci fossero
boldi de sica a guardare i film con noi
magari stringere la mano a volte quello
fatto mente locale ed ho cercato di
ricordarmi gli ultimi avvenimenti per
fare bella figura e mi è venuto in mente
che si è recentemente lasciato con la
compagna e che per rimpiazzare il vuoto
nel suo cuore ha iniziato a frequentare
e recensire escort molto carina
riservata simpatica e un uomo che si
tiene in forma per l'amor di dio come si
evince anche da questa foto di lui
insieme ad una signorina con scritto
venerdì con le trofie voglio dire no a
chi non piacciono le trofie sono
veramente aggiungo c'è anche alla
puttanesca simpatico arrivato in hotel
ho iniziato a di per ventilare per
qualche motivo il non sapere cosa
aspettarvi mi stava uccidendo
non sapevo neppure come vestirmi
elegante e casual orto per una camicia e
via prendo un huber
perché se devo fare l'influenza è visto
cazzo lo faccio fino in fondo ed arrivo
alla sala mentre aspetto alberto ed
edoardo noto un cartello si informa la
gentile clientela che da martedì 18
dicembre il cinema rimarrà chiuso per un
evento privato
cazzo l'hanno chiusa per noi l'anteprima
ma non è vero
infatti tra chi stava aspettando
l'evento chi era semplicemente in coda
alla biglietteria
c'era un casino immenso non si sapeva
devo aspettare mentre siamo in fila
succedono due cose una mi passa de sica
a due centimetri dal naso
quindi due volti sono confermate in sala
2 vedo in lontananza un signore
anzianotto che mi sembrava di conoscere
solo che c'era troppo casino quindi
faccio fatica a capire se fosse
veramente riusciamo ad entrare mentre un
sacco di gente si fa la classica foto
davanti al cartellone non potevamo non
cogliere l'occasione
sono cose che capitano solo una volta
nella vita sarebbe stupido non farlo la
sala è stracolma il pubblico varia da
bambini che corrono a destra ea sinistra
ma me ne da casa fino a gente importante
che fa finta di conoscere tutti quanti
al suono di ciao ciao ciao
tra l'altro i biglietti ci sono stati
dati dentro una busta personalizzata
medusa cinema per la sono tenuta che non
si sa mai
mentre aspettiamo faccio un ripasso
generale di tutti i cinepanettoni dagli
uffici in poi che ho guardato in ufficio
senza farmi beccare da simona non si sa
mai che faccio una domanda dal pubblico
in sala noto di nuovo quel signore che
ho visto all'ingresso ed ora guardandolo
meglio lo riconosco enrico beruschi non
ci volevo credere beruschi e un attore
comico che negli anni ottanta
interpretava vari personaggi di drive in
sono anni che in un modo o nell'altro me
lo porto nel cuore
ho un piccolo sussulto
lì sarà anche un pochino di tristezza
perché é anni che non fa quasi più
niente in tv e al cinema quindi
praticamente nessuno lo riconosce
e stato come guardare al futuro
[Musica]
vivo può corrompere vere vivo vivo
comunque l'attesa si fa sentire
sono elettrizzato ma spaventato allo
stesso tempo in bocca una sensazione
strana quasi agrodolce
e come quando per natale ti fai regalare
un vinile con la registrazione dello
spettacolo del comico preferito ma il
tuo comico preferito e bill cosby ad un
certo punto la sorpresa boldi e de sica
prendono il microfono per dire due
parole prima della proiezione stop per
piangere fa stranissimo vedere due
persone che seguì da anni tra alti e
bassi mesi missy missimi davanti a me a
2 massimo boldi tenta di parlare ma
l'età non glielo permette
de sica con la sua solita classe e
carisma fa un paio di battute che danno
fanno ridere la sala per mettere tutti a
proprio agio ed anche io mi sento
allegro sono pronto a vedere il loro
grande ritorno
[Musica]
è il film è una merda ma per motivi
sbagliati perché l'hanno scritto come
una commedia e non comuni cinepanettone
ma scusa io voglio andare li avete
ruggire panettore ma cosa vuol dire e le
recensioni delle anteprime
lo dimostrano molto meglio di un
cinepanettone
no non è vero l'ho visto lo scrivono
cazzate non è vero
il trailer e le locandine tentano di
farti credere che sia un cinepanettone
ma in realtà è un film sofisticato ma
scusate genia e va bene bravi sono tutti
i brani e spende strade fino a casa un
evento finalizzato alla battuta ma è una
commedia è la commedia e la battuta poi
è interna per l'esterna con personaggi
di malori cazzate l'ex george ma
sciacquati la bocca pazzo non è vero c'è
bondi che condivide su twitter una clip
del film chiamata i fratelli coi ong i
fratelli con il governo il suo 6
viabilità [ __ ] la fama non trova mai
la trama è misses doubtfire con quasi
amici è che comunque praticamente c'è de
sica travestito da donna che fa da
badante a boldi in sedia a rotelle cazzo
lo zero comico è ed è una commedia
troppo troppo classica nonostante ci
siano gli equivoci che rossi arrivano in
una commedia classica ed essendo la
commedia classica ovviamente ci sono non
una non due ma tre battute sono infranti
eva che fanno ridere i prossimi
confronti perché lo dicono così nel 2019
bravi che ridere bravi risate ovunque ma
vi riassumo un attimo le battute con una
scena sola c'è de sica travestito da
donna che sta aprendo la sua macchina
parcheggiata dietro di lui parcheggio
nuovo che vede che lui sta per uscire e
vedere una donna e dj signorina lei sta
per uscire e la battuta è pronta de sica
si gira e un uomo quello lì in macchina
scappa e pronta invece hanno modificato
la realtà de sica si gira e dice a o
sono mossi con la voce modificata ma non
servivo modificarla è già un uomo de
sica che cazzo vuol dire vede
stupidissimo che sta cosa qua e un po
come con totti
c'è un esempio per capire quando la
realtà ma ridere senza doverla
modificare che totti che si allontana
dal mondo del pallone
praticamente lui fa questo discorso di
uno stadio gremito di gente pieno di
gente fa questo discorso strappalacrime
piangono tutti piange la gente piange
conti e piango io che manco seguo il
calcio interna e va fatto però la prima
cosa che fa subito dopo aver fatto
questo discorso strappalacrime e una
pubblicità delle pastiglie della
lavastoviglie fa ridere vedi non serve
modifica la rata fa ridere ed è successa
la stessa cosa con boldi lui a un certo
punto dichiara di utilizzare il viagra
perché c'è una certa età non ci sta e il
primo commento di risposta è stato
scopate né tutte massimo eh ma me fa
ridere a me fa ridere
qui invece l'apice della comicità e la
polpetta per gonfiare il pene
togli purtroppo data l'età non riesce
più ad avere erezioni quindi si fa
impiantare una pompetta per farsi
letteralmente gonfiare il velo come le
piscine per i bambini
e c'è questa scena di noi sdraiato a
farsi a pancia in su con de sica che gli
sta facendo un massaggio shiatsu e si
avvicina un po troppo alla zona del cube
e vuol dire approfitta gli prendi
capelli lo sprint verso il caso e grandi
risate che tra l'altro lo aveva già
fatto avanti con gli stili anche ballato
se nel 79
[Musica]
quando è trash lo fa poco e quando è una
commedia lo fa male questo video sarebbe
potuto essere una recensione classica ma
non lo è
e proprio un commento che mi è uscito
dal cuore non funziona niente niente in
questo film
le uniche cose sono due battute 2 di de
sica perché è bravo lui non perché sia
scritta bene la sceneggiatura
l'unica cosa che mi è rimasta da questa
esperienza è il poter raccontare di
essere stato seduto nella stessa stanza
di enrico beruschi a vedere bolli che
tenta di farsi fare un pompino da de
sica travestito da donna
[Musica]
[Applauso]